Efendim hepiniz hoş geldiniz buraya
davet edilmekte size karşı konuşmak da
çok heyecan
verici Ben Müslüman Mahallesinde kilim
satıyorum 1973 yılından beri ömrümün
çoğu kapal ve etrafında geçti Bizim
çarşının cazip olsa da Muzip bir
mimarisi vardır hani Çarşıyı gezdiniz
gördünüz Her şey tamam evinize
gideceksiniz geldiğiniz kapıya doğru
gidiyorsunuz bir baktınız Yanlış kapı
ters yöne gidiyorsunuz Aynı kapı bir
daha gidiyor Aynı kapı Eğer İlk denemede
çarşıdan çıktınız çıktınız
Yoksa esnaf oluyorsunuz 40 yıl sonra da
ben burada çocukken kayboldum
diyemiyorsunuz Kapalı çarşının büyüsüne
Kapıldım
diyorsunuz aslında bütün suç ta başında
adres sorduğunuz
satıcı size diyor ki İleriden sağa dön
sağ diyor eli solu gösteriyor Ha bir de
bunların yetenekleri vardır Size bakın
bir konuyu anlatırken
bambaşka bir fikri empoze eder
iddialı bir şey değil mi Çok iddialı bir
konuyu anlatırken bambaşka bir konu
Halbuki günlük hayatımızda yaptığımız
konuşmaların neredeyse tamamı
anlattığımız danan başka bir konuyu
anlatır sıklıkla konuştuğumuz anlamı
bile yoktur Bunu bilmeden yapıyorsak
dostluk bilerek yapıyorsak
evlilik
geniş kitleleri yönlendirmek için
yapıyorsak reklam veya
Propaganda eğer biz sustuktan sonra
insanlar bizi hala dinlemeye devam
ediyorlarsa sanat
Olur efendim dünyanın bütün kilimleri
sadece Anadolu kilimleri bütün kilimleri
Yüzlerce belki de binlerce yıldır aynı
kelimeleri kullanılar aynı kelimeleri
her eski kilim içinde anonim bir tasarım
gücünü Barındırır insanlar da tartışır
Dokumacı sanatçı mıdır zanaatkar mıdır
ta
ki şizofren bir kilim sus diyene
kadar Ordu'nun bir köyünde 1960'larda
70'lerde kız dokumuş babası Namaz kılsın
diye ama babası da alını
sürmeden kız ulaşmış nana'ya ulaşmış
bakın Buna da anonim demeniz için kızın
kaynanası olmanız
[Kahkaha]
lazım Vincent Van
hoch veya gırtlak kanseri yapmayan bir
telaffuzla Vincent Van gook erkek olarak
değil de kız olarak Anadolu'nun herhangi
bir köyünde
[Kahkaha]
doğsaydı
Tual üzerine yağlı boya mı
[Kahkaha]
çalışacaktı Kim bilir belki de Vincent
Van gog Anadolu'da
doğmuştur Belki de şu tepenin Ardında
Van gogun sol kulağı
vardır motifler hepsi geleneksel renkler
Ha şimdi aramızdan biri diyebilir ki
efendim ben Van gogun bütün eserlerini
kendilerini gördüm yakından gördüm Ben
bunda Van gogu göremiyorum var mı
efendim ha cesaret eden yok
Ama internetten izleyip de der ya bunda
ne abi ne bunda Van gook nerede Yani
güzel de yerden göğe kadar hak veririm
aynı sebepten ben de
haklıyım karşıt görüşte olsak bile aynı
sebepten Çünkü Bırakın bu bilimi vinson
Van gook hayattayken
Kendi tablolarında bile kimse vinson
voku
göremiyordu tam tersi Van Gogh'un tam
tersine Hollandalı bir ressam Daha
doğrusu
grafiker Morris cornelius
Aser bu ismi duymasan da grafiklerini
sağda solda bir kitap kapağında mutlaka
görmüşsünüzdür en çok sevdiği şey
yaptığı desenlerin arka pla O desenin
bir kopyasını veya karşıtını veya başka
bir desen
oluşturması şimdi bu kilimde eşleri
görmek için biraz eş elemem
gerekiyor Bakın şu Sağdaki siyah desen
bundan 4 tane aynı kareye sığdırdığın
zaman ortadaki boşalan aynı deseni
veriyor kilima döşediğini arka plan
kilimin bir kopyasını yapıyor arka plan
ön plan oyunları Anadolu kilimlerinde
binlercesi var çok güzelleri var ama
burada Eşer ağlatacak bir renk oyunu var
bakın Desenle renk arasında frekansları
aynı ama
şöyle 130'luk bir kayma var bu % 30'luk
kayma çok basit bir hareket aslında
kilimde hiç
olmayan enine panelleri görmenizi
sağlıyor eş yerde var
olmayan Renk faktörü şimdi bu
anlattıklarım geometri
fizik Bunların hepsi sında bir
yalan ben bu
kilimi bunun iç beğendim de
aldım Bütün anlıkları görük
yani geometriyle Fizikle sanat olmuyor
Şimdi ben dükkanda kilimlere böyle
sanatçıların isimlerini veriyor Van gook
eer fr Kafka Emil zola bir gün merak
ettim bir müşteri geldi bir çift Bunlar
da zevk tavanda para
yok kilimleri açıyorum dedim birini
söylemedim yani dedim bunun adını da siz
bilin her şey aynı şey algılamak zorunda
ya değil ya Ya adam Belki o ressamı
tanımıyor
bile adam şu kilime baktı
baktı ezildi
büzüldü Ben de bekliyorum yani aynısını
söylemesini
istiyorum
Clay Paul Clay
dedi adama kilimi bedava
verecektim arkadaşım tuttu
şimdi her müşteri Efendim bunun gibi
değil Siz şimdi Bütün bunlar gelin
çarşıda müşteriye anlatın kadın geliyor
vitrine Vitrindeki kilimin kırmızı
[Kahkaha]
zeminlere cep telefonlarına uyacak halı
kilim aradıkların farkında değiller
bunlar da zaten üretiliyor Avrupa'da
tasarlanıyor Çin'de dokunuyor her marka
ve modele uygun halı
kilim istemediğim kadar İstediğim zaman
alırım satışta Garanti para ödememe
gerek yok benim hedeflediğim % bir de
beyninin sağ lobunda sol lobunda çok iyi
kullanan küresel pazarlama ağına
kapılmam kendi tarzını yaşayan
[Alkış]
Efendim onlarda da ya para
yok ama 160 lira 200 lira verip buraya
geliyorlar O da ayrı
konu çok teşekkür
ederim
Yani bir gölün önünde durmuşum Elimde
bir tası
yoğurt şimdi ben burada ben ben diye
anlatıyorum ama biz Aslında 4 kişilik
bir ekibiz Ben grubun sağcı sol istiyim
Ak sakalımdan dolayı herkes beni postun
şeyhi
zannediyor bizde fikir Kimden çıkmışsa o
an patron odur kimin elinde bir iş varsa
o işin Patronu da odur her şeyde
zaten 23 yıl önce 2012 yılında birden
benim balataları sıyırıp
arkadaşlarım buna önce anlayış Ondan
sonra peşimden uyum göstermesiyle
başladı dükkana müşteri geldiğinde bana
bir kilim böyle tarif ettiğinde Ben de o
kilim her yerde var B de yok
diyordum kaçarsa ben
edebiyat çok da yani anladığımdan değil
hoşuma gidiyor o kadar ama müşteri artık
kilime
odaklanamıyor efendim bir sanat eseri
bir kilim gerçekten içinde sanatsal bir
değer varsa kendi konuşur Yeter ki ona
odaklanıp kafanızdaki anlam bulmaya
çalışmayın zamanla artık pazarlık
yapmayı da bıraktık Şimdi bu muhabbetin
üstüne işte
sen istiyorsun dış verecek 100 do Yani
olmuyor pazarlık yapmak isteyene kartımı
veriyordum 7'ye kadar
açığız derken bir gün arkadaşım Erkan
gitti bu kobra sergisi vardı deneysel
sanatın bin günü onun kataloğu geldi Bir
baktım Aynı bizim kilimler vitrine
koyduk Ondan sonra gitti Claude m'nin
kitabıyla geldi Ben de eşlerin F Goog
kitaplarını aldım Vitrindeki kilim hangi
ressamın hangi resmine benziyorsa onu
koyuyorduk müşteri önyargılıydım
oynuyorduk pozitif ön
yargıya daha
sonra şöyle bir broşür
yazdım ben broşür diyorum müşteriler
Kitap
diyor dünyanın en çok satan kilim
[Alkış]
kitabı Hayır broşürü bedava veriyorum
broşür broşür kilim
satıyor daha baskıya vermeden printerdan
aldığım çıkıy la 3 tane kilim sattım
Otomatiğe bağlamıştım müşteri geliyor ya
vitrine al diyorum sana bir ev ödev
vereyim dolaşıyor geliyor veya dükkanda
mal açıyorum veriyorum kitabı fiyatlar
etikette hepimiz çıkıyoruz dükkandan
müşteri dükkanda eğleniyor karar
verdiğinde bizi
çağırıyor Rıfat kilimi paketliyor Erkan
parayı alıyor Ben de kapattı fincandan
falına
bakıyorum Efendim sürem doldu bağlayayım
zamanla bütün bilim adamların
sanatçılarının falan ilgisini topladık
böyle bayağı şenlik oldu insanlar artık
E bir
ressam kilimini ödemek için resim
yapıyor bir Opera sanatçı dükkanımızda
0u ödemek için la bohemi söylüyor
dışarıda bir grafiker bizim 10 dakika
bizim logomuzu bir saat bizim logomuzu
tartışıyor birinden alfabenin kökenini
dinliyorum sevgililer bizim vitrinim
önünde resim çektiri şimdi bu 3 yıllık
sürecin özür dilerim Biraz uzattım 3
yıllık sürecin ekonomik bir
değerlendirmesini yapalım grafikte
görüldüğü
gibi
parametreler birbirine
uygun Efendim Şaka
yapmıyorum Bu
gördüğünüz ekvadorlu ressam ve heykel
taş Carlo agilo robino bizden aldığı
kilim yapma
yaptığı dört lemen bir tanesi Eğer İşler
kötü gitseydi buraya istatistikle
[Alkış]
gelirdim şimdi gençlerin pek bilmediği
bir deyim var ticarette çırak
çıkmak bir işe girip ondan parasız
çıktığımızda çırak çıktık deriz Biz
esnaf Gömleği Giymiş ne kadar Usta
olursak olalım para kazanırsak kazanalım
biz bu çarşıdan bir gün çırak
çıkacağımızı biliriz ona göre yaşarız
Ama bu işten çok şükür çırak çıkmadık ve
salyangoz satmaktan daha iyi kazandık
Halbuki
günümüzde Müslüman Mahallesinde en iyi
satan şey
salyangoz
Hani ticarette bir deyim
vardır almayanı
dövüyorlar
bütün dünya pasta büyüdükçe küçülen bir
dilimin Biz de sadece kilimin
peşindeydik Şimdilik herkes hayatından
memnun Biz eşya hala ters biniyoruz
onlar da bindiği dalı kesiyorlar Efendim
Ekmek elden yoğurt gölden Hepinize
afiyet
[Alkış]
olsun
h